sport ist ihr tagesgeschäft das team des
hamburger fußball portals fußi freunde
berichtet überregionale spiele das
besondere
viele ihrer texte schreibt eine software
in deutschland gehört die redaktion zu
den ersten die mit roboter journalismus
experimentieren eine künstliche
intelligenz als reporter für
journalisten klingt das bedrohlich pussy
freunde chef dirk becker sieht den
automatisierungs trend aber positiv die
automatisch generierten texte bringt für
uns den riesigen vorteil mit dass wir
wesentlich mehr liegen wesentlich mehr
spiele abdecken können als redaktion
das war vorher mit der gegebenen
manpower schlicht nicht zu schaffen
über 400 vor und nachberichte schreibt
das programm pro woche den rest
übernehmen die redakteure einfache
datenbasierte texte
das bekommt die software am besten hin
entwickelt wurde das programm in berlin
sebastian goalie leitet beim
technologiedienstleister re treskow den
bereich text generierung zusammen mit
seinem team arbeitet er an
automatisierungs programmen eine so
genannte text engine werte daten aus zb
von einem fußballspiel
die daten werden von redakteuren
eingetragen und automatisch an die
software übermittelt
daraus generiert sie artikel mindestens
fünf texte pro sekunde schafft das
programm
aber wann gilt ein team als favorit und
wann spricht man von einem debakel
immer wieder müssen programmierer den
algorithmus anpassen denn auch er macht
fehler es wäre nicht richtig zu
behaupten die engine macht keine fehler
natürlich es menschen im hintergrund
menschen die die engine programmieren
menschen die die regeln festlegen
der große unterschied ist wenn die
internen fehler macht und wir den
korrigieren dann wird sie diesen fehler
nie wieder machen
in den usa ist roboter journalismus
längst etabliert die times lässt eine
software erdbeben meldungen schreiben
das magazin forbes und die
nachrichtenagentur ap setzen ebenso auf
automatisierung auch die forschung
interessiert sich für das konzept ein
team der universität münchen schnell
computergenerierte nachrichten zur us
wahl online die ersten texte auf der
prognose seite pauli wo sind noch
fehlerhaft aber die roboter werden immer
zuverlässiger mein journalismus
forscherin claire worden
die forschung zeigt dass die meisten
leute einen handgeschriebenen text nicht
von einem computer generierten text
unterscheiden können gerade weil es sich
dabei um diese formelhaften beiträge
handelt jeder schreiben könnte
doch was ergibt der praxistest in
hamburg liegen fußballfans zwei
verschiedene berichte zum selben spiel
vor welcher wurde von einer software
geschrieben
im test liegen die meisten probanden
falsch
der spielbericht ist ob also ich würde
jetzt nicht sagen können dass honda
maschine ist hätte ich nicht gedacht
dass das so ausführlich sein kann
gruselig werden journalisten also doch
bald ersetzt unwahrscheinlich denn
algorithmen haben keine meinung können
nicht einordnen
das weiß auch sebastian goalie ich
glaube es gibt ganz viele bereiche des
journalismus die weiterhin sehr gut von
menschen bedient werden und wo der
roboter journalismus nichts zu suchen
hat also ein kommentar zum aktuellen
politischen geschehen wird sobald nicht
automatisch generiert werden
außerdem muss auch jeder roboter artikel
inhaltlich überprüft werden
die software verdrängt hier keine
mitarbeiter im gegenteil durch die
automatisierung hat das fußi freunde
team mehr zeit für hintergrundberichte